[Music]
you know good news though mike
good news now we have time for this
no good bastards baby i was gonna get
away with this yeah but you're not
why'd you make me chose
is he being a tough guy now he's a tough
dude man is he
is he being a tough guy now did you not
know that he was a really tough guy
here we go i just need one
more person to hate me talk
that time one more
problem might
oh wow now you're a tough guy wow
i guess did he take that barricade
garage shot a little bit too
i really you know what i believe it i
actually believe it i believe mike and
tin foil had here
that i know barricade garage does listen
rotc so what's up dude we love your [ __ ]
um i know that we said this is why we
like barricade garage because he has the
balls to say it and then barricade
garage made a video like he said no tom
mcdonald rhymes
and i think that it got to him i would
like to think
it might be my own delusion but we had a
part in this
i really i i know it's a delusion maybe
i'm completely wrong but in my own mind
that's what happened
heartbreaker kicker
[Music]
nasty words he bleeped out ass kicker
yeah because he doesn't leap out the
word ass
because mike he wants to stay monetized
green on youtube
royce yes he bleeped out the word
ass kicker because he wants to stay
monetized green on youtube and the
algorithm picks up naughty words
and then you'll get the does not pick up
ass i don't know
i don't know and he literally said i'm
going to kill them all but then he
bleeped out
ask him it's a good point to take them
[Music]
all
[Music]
nice guy though she really wants to
she's
like you won't be in my video so go
ahead and get
mad i'll show you how easy i turn a
tough guy to a dead man
tough guy tom tommy a tough guy so
here's what i want to point out to all
the boomers right because all the
boomers
love tom mcdonald and like yeah you know
he's all this and that
now he's doing the stuff that all you
boomers complain about rap music which
is just talking about killing people
now he's doing it is he still super cool
i mean i don't care
i [ __ ] listen to wu-tang and [ __ ] you
know and tupac and stuff so
this stuff doesn't really bother me but
this isn't really you know the
the boomer pandering that you would
expect
look man normally and you know you know
the way this bit works i'm turning on
the fourth wall i normally say this is
good this is fun oh why don't you like
it mike
but honestly now he's crossed the line i
can't even do that anymore
i can't even play along with this bit
anymore i'm done because before it was
all this welcome rapping
but him being a tough guy is really
bothering me
him pretending that he's this [ __ ]
tough dude
all this now he's a tough guy rapper
come on you're not tough dude
i just need one more person to hate
me
[Music]
i don't like this guy because he's just
[ __ ] copying the way i look and it's
kind of bothering me
yeah he really is [ __ ] man what's going
on how did he get tom segura in this
video i didn't even think he was like
it does kind of look like thompson or
brook kreicher
i mean pick one all those fat bearded
guys look alike to be fair
[Music]
this is like uh you know it's really
good this is what it is look i
understand that i'm not breaking the
ground by saying this is cringe right
but
how do you like how do you not
see this how do you not see
how this is somebody's calling the guy
with the beard
small show
crackhead you must love it oh yes no yes
she's rabbit i'm back in i took back
what i said i'm back in she's rapping
baby here we go
here we go let's do it you can't hear it
if you don't have the headphones on
you can't hear it if you don't have the
headphones on mike mike put your
headphones on
mike put your headphones you're never
able to hear it you'll not be able to
hear it
you never hear the cool raps you have
all the cool raps
come on you know this is the equivalent
of
no dude you don't understand this is yet
another
guys you're gonna love my girlfriend
she's so talented
she's so funny tom mcdonald is now the
rapping equivalent of the guy that
brings his girlfriend to the podcast
yes party yeah you must love getting
rocks
take your door off the flat head and
take everything that
why you don't think it's cool
why do why is it you notice like her and
him have the same
like tone like the way they the way they
enunciate words
is that like really like 2000's rap
where i'm gonna talk like this and then
over-enunciate this and that oh you
rhymed good job
you want to be on the track yeah why not
at this point [ __ ] who cares
just pay me i don't care anymore let me
put in my purse we need gucci on curves
you think you better the worst and your
family to church so baby don't get on my
nerves like
i don't know about these all i know is
how we go we're non-stop or reload if
you talk and i see
ghosts you groupie baby i'm different
think you know hell i'll show you it i
was born in hell double knows me well i
return with a list like moses did
can you um can we have a sidebar real
quick
yeah sure hold on
i don't care my opinion doesn't change
of what of how cool she is oh yeah no
she's awesome she's so good
i just need one more
[Music]
look i understand i'm going to say
something i i understand that we don't
make a lot of friends
and look at granted i know we don't make
a lot of friends on the internet
um because we like to goof on this stuff
and all that and i'm sure we probably
would be better off way better off
financially and all this stuff if we
actually did but i can't like
i can't bring myself to pretend that
this is good i can't do that
no you know i i mean there's a bit
joking around but obviously surprised
you were able to
carry that bit as long as you did yeah
well only because it made you mad
to be fair but but i i just
it's so don't punch right i'm like let
me tell you something about this
this guy's not on your side guys this
guy isn't
isn't going to be he's not fighting the
culture war for you okay
he's singing about i'm going to shoot
people and i'm going to kill people and
all this stuff
because i have sex with your wife and
not in those words
basically we're just doing the entire
beginning of [ __ ] delivery
yes we are
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] um
hold on let me hear about he looks like
me maybe he's good is this another
this is gonna be another one everybody
gets a bar so we're getting we're
getting guests on the tracks
camron's coming up after him why do they
all sound exactly alike they're all from
canada
but like canadian rappers if you close
your eyes you wouldn't be able to tell
any of these people apart
well because you know it's a girl again
no i wouldn't be able to tell any of
these people apart um
but you ever notice like all right you
ever notice
humor known as how white canadians are
disgusting and they should all be thrown
back in prison
um for those who that say how do you
know that but canada is present
um but like go back and listen like an
old wu-tang album right
you can close your eyes and you know
exactly which member of wu tango oh yeah
yeah
yeah very unique voices everyone had
their own [ __ ] like
uh except kappa donna and you dog god i
always used to get them mixed up
but like i can't tell these people apart
well let's go back to the cake boss
let's see if he's a good rapper a bunch
of cops
afraid to handle themselves we was
raised by the world we ain't afraid to
bleed it helps
you were raised by the wolves wherein
the [ __ ] gritty streets of toronto
yeah the hood of what
by the way the hood of quebec you're not
that ghetto because you probably grew up
in a place where you've seen
literal wolves yeah and that's just not
just
there is no ghettos let's help them out
when rappers are talking about wolves
they're talking about other rappers
trying to kill them not
actual like arctic wolves not actual
wolves
there's a difference
[Music]
you're going to kill people you're going
to kill people you're canadian you're
not even allowed to own a gun
yeah so how are you gonna kill people
how are you gonna kill people with no
gun canadian
making fun of somebody i'm there is is a
hate crime and you go to jail so i mean
i'm not really super worried about you
obviously we're kidding we're not going
to do anything to anybody by the way
before you people [ __ ] was a joke
even if it was a joke
it was a funny like this song it's a
[ __ ] joke
it was it was a funny premise because it
would be funny to watch them go hey
someone call the police that's what
would happen
six feet when i come through guaranteed
to leave you bleeding if you make me
back this truck up
i just need one more person to hate me
todd
can you imagine coming with this [ __ ]
this this [ __ ] [ __ ] and going to
nebraska avenue
you know or or [ __ ] over town i mean
just name the cities he would get killed
in
trying to be this tough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the way forget about tom mcdonald too
this chick
has been trying to be a thing
forever nova is it nova rockefeller is
that this chick has been
like you could just tell she's been
trying to be
a thing for so long
her yes
this chick's been around but like pre
tom mcdonald this chick's been around
just pictures of her like as a teenager
where she was trying to do like music
like this girl has been trying
to do that thing for so long
become bulletproof on our way we dropped
the rule for like we got it all the
loose
i'm the one you told the truth too
[Music]
he's doing her appearances on her videos
for her
and probably getting her people to
produce her stuff she
must have some great a [ __ ]
she must because i mean like this almost
like
i don't know man once like honestly and
guys if you're watching this
i don't care if you're a rap if you're a
rapper just stop
but like if you're a rapper if you're a
podcaster if you're a comedian if you're
a writer whatever you are
separate you and your chick don't don't
let you in your ch
it's one thing to like kind of pop on
each other [ __ ] once in a while but when
you start overlapping too much
it's just stop stop it you look like a
[ __ ]